Elle est allée rencontrer des
Afghans qui sont angoissés.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Normalement, le moment du thé
chez la famille Akbari est
beaucoup plus heureux.
♪ ♪ ♪
Chaque personne, assise à cette
table, craint de perdre
un proche en Afghanistan
depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir
des Talibans.
SHOIB BAKHSHI,
24 ans
- C'est très difficile,
parce que tu te sens un petit
peu... quand tu regardes les
nouvelles, ce que tu entends.
Tu es comme... écoute : Moi,
je suis ici, je suis en
sécurité, puis il y a des gens
que je connais là-bas qui ne
sont pas en sécurité... ça fait
comme... Tu ne peux pas aider
non plus, tu ne peux rien faire.
- Shoib, comme tous les membres
de sa famille, appartient à
une minorité ethnique appellée
Hazara, fortement persécutée en
Afghanistan depuis des siècles.
À la fin des années 90,
son père a été séverement battu
par les talibans, ce qui
a motivé l'exil de sa famille.
Deux de ses oncles, fuyant
aussi les violences, étaient
déjà ici. Ils sont arrivés
le 11 août 2006.
HABIB AKBARI
- C'est sur que c'était
difficile quand on est venu
au Canada parce qu'on ne parlait
pas la langue.
- Comme la plupart
des immigrants, ils ont dû
repartir à zéro. Les deux frères
ont commencé à travailler comme
plongeurs dans un restaurants
de Sherbooke. 15 ans plus tard,
ils sont très bien ancrés dans
la culture.
- On est fiers d'être Québécois
Afghans; ça vient de notre
coeur.
- lls sont maintenant
propriétaires de 27 restaurants
à déjeuners, les Cocofrutti,
une bannière qu'ils ont créer à
la sueur de leur front, en 2014.
- Mais dernièrement, Noor
et Habib n'ont pas la tête
à travailler pour leur
entreprise.
L'arrivée des talibans à Kaboul
fut une journée très sombre.
- C'était terrible pour nous
autres. Ma grand-maman est là,
mon oncle est déjà là. Pour moi
et Habib, c'était une journée...
peut-être pour les autres,
c'était noir comme la nuit;
pour nous autres, c'est plus que
ça parce qu'on a pensé :
Qu'est ce qu'on doit faire?
- Ils consacrent maintenant
la majorité de leur temps à
essayer de sauver leurs proches,
d'autant plus que plusieurs
membres de leur famille ont aidé
les forces armées canadiennes.
À ce jour, aucune réponse
officielle de la part du
gouvernement, seulement
des accusés de réception.
- On a envoyé des courriels
partout pour être capable
d'aider les gens parce qu'on
sait que leurs vies est
en danger.
- Parmi les gens qu'ils tentent
de faire venir au Canada,
Khushnood Nabizada, un ami de
longue date du clan familial.
L'homme est journaliste,
fondateur de l'entreprise
médiatique pro-démocratie
"Khaama Press", et dernièrement,
chef de bureau pour le ministère
de la paix.
Aidé par l'armée américaine,
il a pu fuir le pays le 19 août,
après s'être caché chez un ami.
"La journée que les Talibans
sont entrés à Kaboul, je ne
savais pas où aller, où me
cacher. Je savais que ma vie
était en danger, je suis encore
traumatisé par une récente
attaque à la bombe."
En février dernier,
les talibans ont tenté de
le tuer, alors qu'il était
au volant de sa voiture avec
ses deux enfants. Il se trouve
maintenant dans un camp de
réfugiés en Allemagne,
avec sa famille, en sécurité.
"Je ne suis pas du tout
optimiste pour la suite
des choses. Plusieurs personnes
sont torturées, et les talibans
entrent de force dans
les maisons."
Il n'a aucune idée où il sera
demain, mais s'accroche à
l'espoir de venir rejoindre
sa famille et ses amis, ici.
Il attend, impatiemment,
une réponse du gouvernement
canadien.
"Ce n'est pas facile de tout
laisser derrière, mais pour
sauver ma vie, je n'avais pas
le choix."
Son employé, Nizam Rezahi lui,
n'a pas eu cette chance.
"Je suis présentement caché
chez moi parce que je suis
un journaliste et j'ai écrit
plusieurs articles où
je critiquais ouvertement
les talibans."
La semaine dernière, il a
demandé à ses gestionnaires
de supprimer une vingtaine de
ses articles, mais l'angoisse
est toujours là.
"Ils recherchent présentement
des gens comme moi, je suis
une cible. Je suis très inquiet,
ils peuvent retrouver
mes articles sur internet.
Je suis en danger."
- Il se cache donc derrière
les murs de sa maison, avec sa
femme et sa petite fille de 8
mois, et tente de fuir le pays.
Lueur d'espoir, qui devient par
contre de plus en plus mince
pour Nizam, le Canada où
il pourrait rejoindre ses deux
soeurs à Toronto. Il attend,
lui aussi, une réponse
du gouvernement canadien.
"Les gens doivent savoir ce qui
se passe ici. Oui, ma vie est
en danger parce que je vous
parle, mais dire la vérité est
crucial."
Par-dessus tout, le sort
réservé aux femmes lui fait
faire des cauchemars.
"S'il m'Arrive quelque chose,
personne pourrra protéger
ma femme et ma fille et
ça m'inquiète énormément."
La famille Akbari implore le
gouvernement de ne pas quitter
l'Afghanistan le 31 août et
d'accueillir plus de réfugiés.
La situation est critique,
le danger est imminent.
- Moi, je suis inquiet,
pas comme un musulman,
mais comme un être humain.
- Shoib, du haut de ses 24 ans,
en a gros sur ses épaules.
- Il faut les aider, puis
nous... tout seul, moi, je ne
peux rien faire. C'est sû